question one mm-hmm which of the
following is the graph of y squared
equals f of X this is multiple choice so
you want to think about what is the most
efficient path through this question and
they don't necessarily have to go ahead
and solve everything and work out all
the intercepts in fact you don't need to
do any of that because when you have a
look if you substitute Y squared for f
of X you can see right from this first
line right clearly that's a circle so
that's a second if I'm not recognizing
that that's not extension - that's not
extension one the equation of a circle
is a tunic concept okay so take note
right that should have been an immediate
recognition this must be a circle
question - not gonna say too much about
working out the eccentricity if you swap
them around I always say to any students
I teach how do you remember is an e
squared minus 1 or 1 minus e square what
kind of shape is this going to be if you
have a look at its eccentricity what
kind of value have you got there what's
the size of it what's the size of it
it's going to be larger than 1 right
like I mean you could get a calculator
out to verify that if you buy so that
will tell you it's a hyperbola and then
you go ahead and use the right form okay
question 3
that was that was that was kind of a
free puck there question 4
this is the way that I went about it I
was using the factor theorem so I
substitute in and then I tested a couple
of values right there are probably more
efficient paths through it but that
would have got me there so that's why
you could have just try it out all the
values and then solve that would also
work okay question 5
let's throw on this one for a little
more time okay because this just as
equally comes up in short response let
alone in multiple choice when you see
the absolute value the modulus of Z
minus 1 equals 1 ok you must understand
what modulus is and think distance
distance equals a constant
it's a radius this is a circle okay this
is extension 2 obviously but again that
same recognition it helps you actually
think about what does this thing look
like once you have a picture it's
relatively trivial okay and I did
actually I mean I know we're not marking
it but I didn't look to see for anyone
who submitted any
working for their multiple-choice did
they draw a diagram of any kind and
there was an almost one-to-one
relationship between people who drew a
diagram and got it like the rest of them
is kind of inconsistent you can see the
distance I'm after is from that point up
there I there we go
right up there and you can see it's
actually want a different color you can
see the furthest location is going to be
on the opposite corner right over here I
could talk about the circle geometry
properties that I need but I don't have
to because it's a multiple choice
question okay that interval there has
two parts to it this this part and this
part here okay
so I've worked them out one at a time
and I've gotten my distance root two
plus one okay question sixth no need to
dwell when you square a function you can
see how it behaves with its stationary
points and so on and you can count them
one two three four five every times okay
now a question seven there's the odds
are that means well on this for a moment
because I know a lot of people would
have looked at this and said okay I know
but kind of the point of the extension
to last topic is to be able to say okay
something that you've never ever
encountered and memorized to fullfil how
you're gonna work with that okay just
before this is what you start with okay
now hopefully you should be able to
recognize that this is a parabola and
it's been shifted down so I'm going to
call this x squared minus C no idea what
C is bit doesn't matter okay
now when I then take this basic fact and
think about all of these other options
here okay it's easy to eliminate some of
them really easy okay I think the first
easy wants to eliminate are a and B hey
which says which one is it it's that one
square root of the whole thing and B
which has the square root in the middle
doesn't it yes okay tell me why these
two are so easy to eliminate as possible
answer
any suggestions okay so if you look at
part a it has a range restriction on
immediately you don't need to know
anything about it to say why can only
take on positive values and zero which
disqualifies it from the graph that
you're looking at right now because it
obviously don't obey that right okay sir
yes the other way around right here X
has to be greater than or equal to zero
and you don't need to think about any
more interesting point
if this repeated a short response and I
asked you for graph this even if I gave
you this this is kind of interesting
because if you say okay y equals a
squared is minus C no sorry I want the
square root of the square root of x okay
wait no I keep it you're wrong it's the
spirit of X rules with fun okay
yeah thing about this toggle or check
that is so no check this is straight
line okay but it's not just a straight
line it's certainly not this straight
line right what's the difference you
just taught me to do this it has a
domain restriction so this this weird
guy is actually this right and a circle
right there okay that's an interesting
question
didn't get to ask it okay but again
something I can clearly exclude okay
what's that last one this one here
that's D I think deep
what is that me I I'm not really used to
it in this form okay
I would probably rearrange this a little
bit and maybe swap this guy and this guy
where would that be happier that so I go
this equals this yeah what's that guy
that's a rectangular hyperbola okay now
that's not bad but it's certainly not
what I've got okay so just have a look
at this now let's come back okay let me
demonstrate so here's a x squared minus
C okay there we can verify remember we
did not even talk about the shape right
but do you remember what I knew about
the square root of FX it has a range
restriction so it sure enough that's
what it looks like okay if you have a
look at this guy
there's that straight line I was telling
you about right and it's got its domain
restriction
okay here's our hyperbola shares some
important features with the parabola
okay but it's not what I want what
happens when I apply this absolute value
in here there's that circle there in the
middle okay and it is a circle how do
you know it's a circle in case you
actually do get asked this in extended
response how did he about this let's go
back I need some I need some paper
let me make a new page okay here's what
we're looking at right y squared equals
the absolute value of x squared minus C
is what I'm suggesting right now
anything about what does in absolute
value mean like it's a shortcut it's
shorthand it's an abbreviation it's for
either you can think about the square
root type of thing but in my case I read
what I think that the plus/minus there's
two parts to this right
so sometimes sometimes Y squared is x
squared minus C when when is it when is
the absolute value of a equal to a for
what values of a when a is positive
right or equal to zero you guys know
that zero doesn't matter okay so for me
what that means is when X square
- see is positive that's that same
parabola that means it's on the outsides
right so the square root of C sorry X is
less than or equal to the square root of
negative C or X is greater than this
greater C so I'm on the outsides right
and that showed you that hyperbola we
got before because that was exactly what
we said for Part D that was that answer
remember what's the other answer
what else could Y squared be equal to ya
it's the negative case right C minus x
squared where is equal to that in what
in what domain not the outside but the
insides right because it's when x
squared minus C is less than or equal to
0 the inside part of the parabola and of
course when you just rearranged tada
there's your circle make sense ok so the
reason why I'm going through this detail
is not because of this particular
question it's just 1 mark obviously but
this would be a great question what a
shame I cut put in your AP for examinee
more let's turn over the page okay
question 8 won't dwell on that one too
much you really did need to know to get
that in the right form make the
right-hand side equal 1 you can see my
working there crunch out your a and your
B values and go ahead and you can work
out what the equations of the directions
are alright let's look quickly at 9 this
question was poorly done again like I
said complex numbers we just kind of
leave it alone don't we okay
think about what it means to multiply
complex numbers that's my left hand
diagram right there and think about what
it means when you concatenate them when
you just add them or subtract them
together right think about your vector
geometry that's how this works best and
you can see my diagrams you can see I'm
understanding how multiplication gives
me the rotation okay u equals Z W that
could work and in the same way how I
think about the vectors in the way they
relate
yeah looks justified me like I could get
down to the real axis right so that's
that's how I've logic tit out and both
of these statements are geometrically
plausible that's all I need right and
question 10 again that was a free
okay